one of the things that we like to do one
of the forms formats that we play with a
lot and I think successfully is we will
take something very familiar and serve
it in an unfamiliar way but then we will
take things unfamiliar and serve them in
familiar ways because I think taking
something unfamiliar and serving in an
unfamiliar way is maybe you run the risk
of asking too much of people and I don't
mean that as a in a derogatory way but I
still I still think as a society where
people people are beginning to see that
the dining eating can be an art form but
it's not it's still not sky's the limit
no holds barred all the time with eating
as it is with other art forms painting
sculpture there it's you know go
wherever you want and wilt and we'll
decide there but it's still eating
people still you know you you have to
eat you don't have to paint you don't
have to do these other things and so I
think there's there's still a large
number of people that eating is about
sustenance and it's not about a creative
process or anything like that so that
being said we like to I think a very
successful way of delivering food in the
restaurant is something familiar like
eggs benedict we will take that apart
and serve it to you in a way that does
not resemble the eggs benedict of your
childhood or of Sunday brunch or of
whatever your particular memory of eggs
benedict is but when you eat it you can
still be transported it's still all the
flavors that it still taps the memory of
eggs benedict but we serve in an
unfamiliar way we break it down we
deep-fry the hollandaise we poach an egg
yolk and shape it in a restructure in
another way we we do a lot of things but
when you eat it you go on I'm still
having eggs benedict that can still like
the taste is linked to memory and and
that usually makes often makes for a
successful dish when you can eat
something and have it tap a memory as
long as that memory is positive then
then you can that's that's a good way
for us to serve you but then if we take
a combination of things for instance
again addition we're going to put on the
menu today
is uh it's going to be veal brisket with
honeydew melon ricotta cheese black
olives and green tomatoes and those are
flavors that probably don't sound they
might sound disparate to some people why
do I want olives with my melon y ricotta
and and and green tomatoes or well that
doesn't sound to me it doesn't sound
crazy but there are there elements of
that dish that maybe don't sound like
they're going to go together but we're
not going to present it in a very weird
presented in a way that's going to make
it seem friendly going to make it make
you want to interact with it friendly in
a nice way it's gonna it's gonna it's
not going to be intimidating and I don't
and again I'm hesitant because I don't
want to challenge it sound like I'm
challenging people but I think for
instance another dish that we do is we
have a a wall-eyed pike that we served
with mashed potatoes yeast zucchini and
distortions and again mashed potatoes
flavored with yeast is something that
probably at first glance you think well
they taste funky they taste like they're
off because yeast has that that that
funk that that that yeast enos to it
that is what makes beer so delicious and
bread so wonderful but it also is
something that is approaching an off
note but when you have a piece of fish
with mashed potatoes and a vegetable and
a sauce then you're using a framework
that's familiar to people but we're
delivering flavors that are a little
unfamiliar or a lot unfamiliar but we're
presenting it in a way that is familiar
that people can sort of say ah ok I see
my mashed potato pile I see my fish I
see my pile of vegetables ok I get it
and then as they begin to eat it they
are hope is that someone would say oh
wow ah yeast that's that I had that
never would have I didn't think of that
or Wow nasturtium it's that's
interesting I don't even know what that
is and how
what I don't understand how they cook
this fish but the texture is fabulous
and you know and some people don't even
notice that but though for those that do
I think that that we have found that
those are successful ways of delivering
food to people familiar things in
unfamiliar ways and unfamiliar things
and familiar ways and i hope i've sort
of qualified that in a way that makes
sense